Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192. David P. If you have
anything to say, comment, question. Concern,
complaint. You can call 2192. David P You know,
in the midst of all of these problems for
the right, here's a caller reminding us
about a very important story that no one's
talking about anymore. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Okay. This is Chuck from Minneapolis.
What about Obama gate? They could have downgraded
the Obamas for that if you forgot about Obama.
You know what it is. All right. Thanks. Bye.
Speaker 1: Yep. Whatever happened with Obama
gate, you might remember that during Donald
Trump's first and so far only presidential
term, he started talking about Obama gate,
which he described as the greatest political
crime of the century. When he was asked, Sir,
what is Obama gate? He angrily told a reporter in
the press briefing room. You know what it is, and
no one knows what it is. But if there is anything
ripe for a raid, I guess it would be this vague
Obama gate. I don't know. We have a great bonus
show for you today. In the midst of all of this
economic good news and bad MAGA news. Joe Biden's
approval rating has spiked to its highest point
in two months. Things are really turning around
for this guy. We're going to talk about it on the
bonus show. We will also talk about a new report
that says Rainwater is not safe to drink because
of the chemicals that are in it. And we will talk
about the growing sort of I hate to call it this,
but it's kind of a pissing match between
Apple and Samsung or really iPhone and Android
where texting between the two platforms is
increasingly broken. I'm going to explain to
you what's going on and the behind the scenes of
it. Very, very interesting. Corporate wars. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Pac-Man's a loser.
Speaker 1: Alex Jones hates the bonus show. I
love the bonus show and I would love for you
to sign up at join pacman com. See you
there today or tomorrow on the Friday.